what do you actually do your private  investigator you a bodyguard you could  call me like a jack-of-all-trades  Greg Barrett hired me to find you  actually I found him  she had this flash drive had an  algorithm Varna she could read emails  text messages phone calls anything the  class should have his breakfast without  me I know what everyone's does and says  and that is worth hundreds of millions  of dollars what are you actually who  about her magic flash drive to get  inside the NSA database network you  stick with this crow and you're gonna  wind up dead  coming after you now I know this isn't  just about insider trading what did you  do  bring it up bring it up  and all these you live in Chilton our  system  these people  I'm going to win this fight like it or  not